the most heroic thing we can do now
is look the truth in the face night king
is coming
the dead are already here
the night king made them all they follow
his command
if he falls
getting to him may be our best chance if
that's true he'll never expose himself
yes he will he'll come for me
hi everyone it's charlie this is going
to be my game of thrones season 8
episode 3 trailer video obviously the
big battle of winterfell
so we got to talk about the footage
that's going on here the plan that they
made
who we think is going to survive who we
think is going to die and what the big
twists are going to be because i don't
think any of us expect the battle to go
down the way they think it will based on
the planning session that they had and
what brand told them
remember what tyrion said during the
episode sometimes clever people the most
clever people
overestimate their cleverness and bran
thinks he's pretty clever right now
so if you're new to my channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the game of
thrones videos there's a new round of
that hbo now giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video
so we'll start with the footage first
and what the people are saying during
the trailer the obvious stuff then we'll
talk about what we think is misleading
what's missing from the trailer then
we'll talk about death predictions so we
start with a voiceover from
sansa saying the most heroic thing we
can do now is look the truth in the face
she's probably referring to the fact
that just looking their own deaths in
the face like we all might die tonight
because most of the characters are fair
game to die they're only a couple of
people that i think
are safe with plot armor and have to
survive the last couple of episodes
but based on what tormund told them when
he arrived with the brothers of the
night's watch
the white walkers are arriving just
before dawn it makes it sound like the
battle will end by dawn
meaning most of this will take place in
the dark and it looks like the white
walkers create a winter storm
to cloud their vision to make it much
harder for them to coordinate their
armies
make all the jokes you want about
cranking the brightness up on your
screens
so much of my time after i finish making
game of thrones videos is just going
back
into the edit and cranking the
brightness way up so that everybody can
just pick out what's going on in each of
the frames because of the way they light
stuff
they give you a bunch of different views
of their combined armies standing in
formation
starting with the unsullied legions the
trebuchets the smaller catapults the
siege weapons in front but you have the
dothraki blood riders standing in front
of them
then you have jon snow up on a hill face
looking down on their forces of
winterfell from a nearby cliff
they're both dragon riders now because
jon has learned to ride regal so maybe
this is them just taking the dragons for
a loop around the area to get a better
look at things before the start of the
battle
samwell watching the unsullied march by
we haven't seen a lot of samwell footage
from the other trailers in this big
battle scene so i'm assuming that he's
just gonna help the others inside the
castle when the whites eventually make
it over the wall
samuel tarly slayer of white walkers
lover of ladies so if we need any more
signs the world was ending orient sansa
up on the walls davos elsewhere also on
the walls walking past the northern
soldiers
down in the crypts it's varus gilly
little sam the little girl that gave
davos the shireen baratheon flashback
it's a little too blurry and dark in
here to see which stark tomb they're
sitting next to but we'll probably get a
better look for it during the episode
but they're probably on the upper levels
of the crypts the underground structure
has
way more levels goes way deeper in his
way larger
than the actual above ground winterfell
castle i did a whole history video on
the crypts of winterfell a little while
ago but they go back to the time of bran
the builder
the lower you go the older the tombs are
i know there are a lot of people asking
what's going on with this plan to put
them in the crypts because it's all dead
people they're sitting around dead
people
the nike and the white walkers raise
things as whites well here's the thing
about that i think there are a couple
practical reasons why the people in the
crypts are mostly safe not completely
safe but mostly safe
the doors to the crips are made of
really thick iron wood which is
impervious to most kinds of fire
and it's almost as strong as steel but
also number two i think the gilly and
little sam are
safe so i think that most of the people
around here would be safe
because if you turned one or two of
these people then the rest would be dead
because they really are
fish in a barrel so they'll probably be
some moment where the whites almost
bang down the door before they're able
to stop them above ground
they'll probably take it right to the
edge like the whites almost get into the
crips but they don't quite make it in
so i'm not expecting any really big
danger for the people down here
there's a shot of tyrion elsewhere
outside on the walls sir jorah up on the
line in the thick of it on horseback
with heart spain thank you very much
samwell be sure to give that back when
you're done with it unless you die then
sam will have to go find it himself
john says the night king is coming but
there's a shot of him on the ground with
smoke all around him because of that
winter storm that they create so it's
really hard to tell where he is
during this shot but it looks like he's
seeing something he can barely believe
the expression on his face is one of
shock and surprise
there's a much wider shot of their
armies outside the gates of winterfell
this is actually lit pretty well
there's the dothraki blood riders up in
the front the siege weapons behind them
the unsullied legions these people over
on the bottom right here with the taller
looking shields and some of the
dragonglass pikes seem like they're the
northern soldiers
i'm assuming the knights of the vale are
standing off to one side here just off
of frame
there's the same shot of arya running
through the upper levels of the castle
probably from
some whites chasing her who have made it
over the walls she doesn't have her
special weapon that gendry made for her
so she may have lost it at this point
maybe she still has that valerian dagger
on her hip there's another shot of the
unsullied legions outside the castle as
the winter winds blow all around them
this probably just means the army of the
dead is much closer to them and the
winds that they're creating are just
making it much harder and harder for
them to see getting thicker and thicker
that's actually a really creative use of
their powers create a giant winter wind
to obfuscate
their vision so it's much harder to
coordinate and it makes it way harder
for the dragons in the air like daenerys
and jon snow
to see what they're doing there's the
hound with his new dragonglass axe and
barrick with his usual flaming sword
inside the castle looking like they're
trying to hunt
something down they're literally trying
to be really careful so something is
clearly going on
inside winterfell during the battle
there's a shot of what seems like
daenerys on drogon's back
amidst this giant winter storm just
trying to survive through it
i saw a lot of questions about what's
going on with this dragon in my feed
but if you look on its back there's a
little tiny figure with long white hair
blowing all around in the wind and
they're hugging the dragon back as close
as possible like they're trying to hunch
over to avoid this winter storm
so that's why i think that this dragon
is drogon and it's daenerys on his back
i don't think that it's the night king
of viserion
because viserion is a much deeper shade
of blue with piercing blue eyes and the
teeth coming out of his mouth look way
more menacing than drogon's teeth they
just designed him to look like a much
more fearsome dragon now that he's a
white than drogon even though drogon is
much bigger in size
the unsullied legions enter their battle
posture then there's theon
in the godswood with a flaming
dragonglass arrow getting ready to
protect bran with the other ironborn
jon snow pulling out long claw near a
tree this might be the godswood too but
it's really hard to tell
i'm guessing that wherever he goes
during the battle he won't stray too far
from winterfell
then daenerys turns to jon snow and says
the dead are already here
still pretty clearly pissed about what
happened at the end of episode two
the rhaegar fell on the trident she had
a son
robert would have murdered the baby if
he ever found out and liane knew it
but they leave the trailer off with
brienne shouting to pod and the knights
of the vale to stand their ground as it
seems like the legions of whites have
already started making their run on
winterfell like here they come right now
i know a lot of you are hoping for ice
spiders biggest hounds
because we barely got a wide shot of the
white walkers marching their horses into
frame so we haven't got a full shot of
the army of the dead yet so you don't
know what else they're gonna surprise us
with
but outside of the giants that the white
walkers have turned and maybe a few
other large animals i'm not gonna hold
my breath for giant ice spiders even
though that would be
really really cool there were a lot of
people that were confused about this
shot of the white walkers marching into
frame two
because a lot of people saw the curved
ice blade in the middle here that the
night king uses
and they thought that this person might
be him but you notice that the night
king does not have a beard
the person with the curved blade here
has a beard so that is not the night
king it's just another one of gilly's
presumable cousins that's right they're
all fighting gilly's family that's who
all these white walkers are as far as we
know
what is the big twist of the episode
though is that we don't see the night
king anywhere in this trailer but
they're all convinced that he's coming
bran made this huge plan
to try and trap him or lure him out into
the godswood using himself as bait
i think it's important to remember what
tyrion said to jaime during the episode
about all his
failures in battle planning i made a
mistake common to clever people
i underestimated my opponent so think
about it this way
maybe the night king has been using
brand's abilities against him
because bran said that the night king
has been trying to kill all the
three-eyed ravens going back
thousands of years unsuccessfully so the
night king is not
dumb all those three-eyed ravens had the
advantage of unbroken
magical seals protecting them when he
broke the seal by grabbing brandon
marking him
that's really what tipped it off and we
know that bran is still kind of learning
his abilities he's much better than he
was last season but he still doesn't
know everything
so in the way that clever people
underestimate their opponents i think
that bran
is underestimating the night king jon
snow made it sound like it would be the
easiest thing in the world we just kill
the night king and we take care of all
this stuff
clearly that is not going to be the case
the battle will not go down the way they
think
so let me know in the comments what do
you think that the night king is going
to do to swerve on their plan
to trap him during the episode he could
either not show up at
all or he could only show up for a
couple minutes in the episode and then
completely take off leaving them
confused wait a minute where'd the night
king go will we still have all these
white walkers and whites to defeat
as far as death predictions go though
this is a solid episode for them to shed
a lot of their secondary characters and
maybe a few main characters too
and don't forget a few characters might
come back as whites during the battle
they're only couple though i'm not
expecting every single dead person to
come back as a white but i think it's
actually better to say which characters
we think
are totally safe so these are the
characters that i think are wearing plot
armor and have to survive to at least
the last couple of episodes
you have jon snow daenerys and at least
one of the dragons probably drogon
is safe arya stark samwell gilly little
sam
tyrion and the little bear like we saw
ghosts during last week's episode i
think it's possible that they could kill
ghosts during this episode nymeria is
still alive so if she and her super pacs
show up 50 50 on whether or not she
survives the battle
pretty much anyone in the north that's
not on my plot armor list is fair game
to go
including melisandre because i think
they're gonna almost lose the battle
really really badly but i'm expecting
some sort of melisandre
knights of the veil moment during the
third act with the red priests or
whoever it is that she went over to get
support from it's just assuming that it
would be other red priests and maybe the
fiery hand
she even prophesied her own death when
she was talking to varys before she went
back to volantis
so don't worry i'll be back because we
have to die in this strange land
let me know in the comments though do
you guys actually think that melisandre
will show up during the battle at some
point
what'll happen too is i will do a q a
video but that'll probably post on
wednesday
because i'm allowed to post my
non-spoilery avengers end game review
tuesday afternoon
so look out for that we have both
avengers end game this week and the
biggest battle
in game of thrones history so be sure to
stay alive
all week so that you get to see it all
it is going to be an amazing
week but congratulations to the last
giveaway winner andy arzuza please email
me on the about page of my channel so i
can get your details
while you wait for everything click here
for my game of thrones season 8 episode
2 video
and click here for my episode 1 video
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome i'll see you
guys tonight